hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the try not to laugh
challenge now if you look closely you
may notice that there's something a
little bit different about me I'm
wearing glasses look at my cheeks I'm
thick
I'm just thick I'm a big boy thick I'm
dummy thick you know the doctors didn't
think it was possible for my head to get
any bigger but here we are so I just had
my wisdom teeth pulled I I just got my
teeth ripped two days ago it still hurts
like hell and one of the things that the
doctor said is I shouldn't talk very
much so here I am being an idiot and
talking but number two I think that also
means that I shouldn't laugh because
every time that I've laughed since I got
my surgery it hurts like hell
so I think that's as good a motivation
as any to try to do a try not to laugh
because I am made of steel I may be
thick but I'm tough I ain't flabby
I'm floppy I'm I ain't flabby I'm firm
I'm firm thick I'm not jealous ick I'm
I'm like pudding thick either way this
this thick don't shake and so I ain't
gonna laugh so I've got some videos in
front of me of with which I'm not going
to laugh at make sense I've already done
too long of an intro let's get into it
[Music]
Wow that was perfect form
what a beautiful [ __ ] when it comes to
one-year-old Dante Pierre you are the
[Applause]
[Music]
both him and me ow
saundra what they addicted after
everything that I say when someone's on
drugs there when someone drink alcohol
what hit you in the face last night
adidas what the [ __ ] again that's not
the first time that's happened
that's not first time a dick hit you in
the face the bullet would you want to go
to dinner sometime okay never mind all
right
[Music]
Oh my normal my normal my normal method
of not laughing is to suck in uh-huh oh
but it was so good
[Music]
I'm in agony I'm in hell this is hell
this hell oh my god oh if I put myself
through
oh that explains everything you
dispersed your that that explains
everything
no mmm don't like this that's all right
this is the same kind of energy is that
that guy you know what I'm talking about
arrow knows what I'm talking about I
don't know man look I'm trying guys I
can't jiggle them much my thickness
moves oh hi
[Music]
[Music]
I feel it's my favorite look how calm
she is as well
[Music]
sorry
what is she trying to do oh she trying
to do superhero move oh oh just a
[ __ ] mess
everybody ignore my bitching oh this is
all I can do to smile this is my smile
this this is my smile look at the mood
day is high day
I hate he hit me
I hate me right now me sucks means too
thick you know I was reaching for my
dreams of thickness and I just went too
far I went too far I went too far into
the thick oh nice bird Oh hmm you know
when I look like you know what I look
like hang on you know what I look like
right now
yeah you know it looks like right now I
look like the thumbnail from my very
first video that's what I look like
right now but no Photoshop it's just my
face all right here keep going
oh I can't look at any more I lost like
two seconds in I don't know what
happened to me I don't know what I was
expecting I don't know why I bothered
I'm not taking my thick ass back to bed
I'm gonna get an ice pack for my thick
ass face and my thick ass ass and I'm
just gonna I'm more relaxed and I'm
gonna try to forget that this ever
happened so if you guys want to see more
try not to last where I'm actually
coherent but just as giggly and in
moderately less pain I'll provide a link
in the description or the suggested
videos probably have some try not to
laughs as a playlist if you've got more
videos or you want me to laugh at put
them in the comments below or some I
don't know I should probably set up a
system for that but thank you everybody
so it's watching my cheeks will deflate
in due time but in the meantime thank
you for watching if you want to see more
cool stuff smash the subscribing button
make that sub button nice and thick just
as thick as my face or the like button
or the Bell I don't really care
pick one of the three in just you know
give it a mean smooch I'll be nice so
thanks again and as always I will see
you
next video bye-bye